what a year you're having so well
deserved how is life treating you uh
honestly no complaints right now it's
been quite the year personally got
married and then Wednesday came out and
it's just been so fun I mean to have
such success in your personal life and
your professional life unbelievable
let's talk married life for a second
yeah does it feel different
you know we've lived together for like
four years so
the day-to-day is pretty much the same
but uh you know it feels more just solid
and I love him yeah and the success of
Wednesday massive congratulations I mean
you guys just broke streaming record
after streaming record do you make a
habit scaring the hell out of people
it's more of a hobby congratulations
season two thank you so much do you know
if you're coming back yeah coming back
um and can't really say anything else
besides that but I'm so excited to go
back you know I know obviously your lips
are sealed I will ask you have you seen
scripts no I haven't so I'm not even
hiding anything I really don't know
first year yeah I will tell you you know
we've talked to Jenna and we said if
there is a season two like what would
you want to see the evolution of
Wednesday be like I kind of want her to
be darker I want to continue down an
anti-hero stream rather than typical
hero what do you see for season two if
you could fish your wish and give the
fans you know your vision for season two
I'm really excited because now that
Tyler's secret is out of the bag I'm
excited for season two to kind of
explore him fighting between the monster
and the real version of him and also he
doesn't have his master Christina Ricci
anymore so what's he gonna be like I
don't know
what does a season two without Christina
Ricci look like or is she coming back is
she gonna come back in some way I don't
know I hope so can can we make that
happen you tell Tim Yeah Tim yeah and
then to see the show have a second life
on Tick Tock are you on Tick Tock do you
watch all these celebrities doing the
Wednesday dance yeah Lady Gaga did it I
mean that was insane yeah what do you
make of you know maybe just aimlessly
scrolling one day on your phone and
you're just like constantly seeing your
show your work you know as such a big
part of Pop Culture yeah it's really
funny because the dance is obviously
what blew up in Jenna just kills it and
that scene I basically just stand there
in the like smile stupidly so it's
really fun to see all those videos but
I'm so happy like I mean Jenna deserves
all the success in the world you all do
you're all a very talented group of
people I know there's a lot of eyeballs
on Jenna right now and the way that
she's kind of handling this massive
influx of Fame what do you make of that
oh God she's doing a stellar job and
she's getting it like you know tenfold
what the rest of us are having to deal
with so yeah
you say Jenna's getting it you know a
little more than you are but has your
life changed are you going to the
supermarket and getting recognized more
yeah it does make you like not want to
like look like when you leave the house
the most interesting fan encounter that
you've had yet oh um I did come out of a
dressing room to a family waiting on me
to take a picture
yeah very sweet person is this happening
like
frequently now uh pretty frequently yeah
it's it's it's bizarre
my final question before I let you go I
know this is tough but if you could
describe Wednesday season two in three
adjectives
what would you choose I can't do it I
don't know yet I already told you I
don't have the scripts so I'm just I'm
waiting like everybody else
[Music]